[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is very
exciting this is the long in my opinion
overdue episode with Maria Bamford one
of the funniest and most talented people
to ever perform stand-up comedy and she
is wonderful go to Maria bamford.com for
her tour dates and her book sure I'll
join your cult and all different sorts
of projects it just if Maria Bamford is
doing it do yourself a favor and check
it out I'm so excited she's here I'm
also super excited that we have a new
Pete's pick on this episode first time
out the gate this has absolutely changed
both my life and Val's life for the
better by helping us naturally produce
more oxytocin I'm sure you've heard
about oxytocin it is the feel good
hormone and this supplement is known as
golden hour by first person first person
designs Precision Precision excuse me
targeted supplements made with
functional mushrooms that aim to
stimulate the body's natural production
of specific neurotransmitter that
triggers activities like energy mood and
sleep and golden hour does just that
helps me tune in to a sense of Joy
connection and relaxed presence it is
unbelievable I noticed it the first time
I took it within about 15 minutes and
the effect has built over time now that
I take it every day it just keeps
getting better using those Precision I
can't say Precision today Precision
targeted mushrooms golden hour supports
the body's natural production of
oxytocin that mitigate stress and boosts
the Mind Body Connection and may even
help promote long-term cognitive Health
but that's not all I loved golden hour
so much I now take all three of the
first person family of supplements and
I'm so glad I do Sunbeam maximizes
productivity and create creative
activities by tuning in to an inspired
focused mindset by supporting the body's
natural production of dopamine to
activate the brain's motivation and
reward system and Moonlight helps me
stay in deep restorative sleep longer
awake feeling clear and well rested by
supporting the natural production of the
Gaba neurotransmitter so we have
mushrooms targeted at these different
parts of our brain and it is incredible
and it's even better when you stack them
they're meant to be stacked they build
on each other and complement one another
so when I'm sitting down to work I take
both Sunbeam for dopamine and golden
hour for oxytocin so I feel joyful and
motivated and of course I take Moonlight
at bed that gives me that perfect
night's rest deep and without getting up
it's incredible it's 100 grain free
organic mushroom as well as highly
curated blend of nutraceuticals first
person is a game changer so start
improving your brain health and
cognition with first person you can get
20 off your first order by going to
getfirstperson.com and use promo code
weird and these statements I have to say
I have not been evaluated by the Food
and Drug Administration these products
are not intended to diagnose treat cure
or prevent any disease but go get first
person.com promo code weird twenty
percent off support your brain support
the show I'm absolutely obsessed
speaking of Obsessed this is my Apollo
neuro but there's one piece of tech if
you guys have ever seen me at a show or
even on TV I'm always wearing my Apollo
neuro because it has changed my life
hands down more than any other piece of
technology that I own the Apollo neuro
is a new wearable that helps your body
recover from stress by sending
vibrations into your body that sends
nervous uh sends signals to your nervous
system by giving it the sensation of
being touched or held Apollo can help
you relax sleep focus and be more
productive it's like a wearable hug for
the nervous system using touch therapy
to help you feel safe and in control if
I do something very stressful uh like I
don't know visiting home or something I
put it on rebuild and recover if I'm
traveling a lot I put it on uh unwind
the whole time I'm on the plane and it's
just giving my nervous system the signal
it's okay it's okay it's okay and it
lulls you and you feel your shoulders
rest and you just merge into what is you
can wear it on the wrist or the ankle a
polyneur is like finding the fuse box
for your emotions with settings for
energy feeling social clear and focused
rebuilding and recovering calm which is
great for meditation unwind which is
great for getting sleepy before bed and
fall asleep which is great it's a
non-chemical way allow yourself back to
sleep Apollo neuro was developed by a
neuroscientist and a board-certified
psychiatrist who have been setting the
impacts on chronic stress in humans for
nearly 15 years and their effect on
stress sleep cognitive performance and
Recovery have been proven in multiple
clinical trials so give it a try 10 off
at apollonuro.com weird support your
body support the show APO l o n e u r
o.com slash weird and I am on the road
go to petomes.com I'm going to be at
Largo on September 5th hope to see you
there if you're in Los Angeles in the
meantime enjoy my chat with the
hilarious and wonderful Maria Bamford
get into it
here we go just get in
get in here just jump in take it off run
inside
I'm wearing a gladiator sandal I am of
course
these are my dead mother Sanders I was
going to ask are those your Dead Mothers
every time I see you I go are those your
dead mother's frames no but uh she did
have some like this those went to my uh
my niece uh my niece wanted them are we
pissed about that wow there's a little
tug of war back and forth and I said
we're hurting the glasses I mean these
aren't they're durable but they're not
yeah when did your mom that was like uh
four years ago and my dad just passed
away about what if I was like and you're
still wearing the sandal like I think
you should be over it no no and we're
still thinking about her move on
she's these are great sandals turns out
my mom buys a hearty sandal a fashion
and they're fashionable and they're
fashion well I mean I guess Barbie wears
a a sort of sandal like this so I guess
it is fashionable at this moment I'll
tell you what why I thought it was
fashionable was that you you say OCD is
the new Gladiator sandal and only on
that I go I guess gladiator sandals are
cool because you wouldn't say that it
was like they're the new they were at
that time I think that was in the I
don't know in the tens
um are we is this a show is it happening
this is the show is that okay okay no
that's okay no I get I get anxious like
I'm like is this the show or am I can I
open on this
no is this for me yeah it's also for you
oh this is that's about that's a little
bit of caffeine and then classy
adaptogens that help calm you it's sort
of like a I don't know how to describe
it but it helps you calm down and focus
and you're welcome oh my god I've
already had a Nitro cold brew but I'm
gonna put this in my purse yeah like the
old woman that I am and drink it later
wet wet fruit sorry I've been listening
to your comedy oh thank you so much and
it also just as a fan but like today I
you have such a way you have such a way
with words I love people give your
voices and your characters and your and
your style which all deserve a lot of
credit but I really love your language I
think you're a genius writer super fun
we're trying we're all trying we're
trying to try
oh have a sip of that water yes I will
okay okay I'm gonna I'm gonna Vamp okay
ah bamboo Bamboo thank God that's over
no
okay so what is now your podcast is
there something I should be covering is
there something is there a way to uh I
think you're in very safe Waters give
them your interests and your style okay
I I love that you said that you what do
you say you preemptively you're
preemptively honest like prevented oh
preventatively honest yeah so if anybody
yeah I just want to let everybody know
but I also think that as a safety
measure if you tell everybody what's
going on inside you maybe somebody will
say hey hey D looks like you're
struggling like yeah like you might get
a little
um there's so much mental health care
options you know through social media
like everybody's educated about it now
yeah so somebody might say oh that looks
like uh uh like you're going into an
episode isn't that interesting it's nice
no you're absolutely right uh emotional
vocabulary is going through the roof uh
like it's very I have a daughter it's
very common to hear other parents I
thought it was just us like hippie West
Coast but you go all around the country
and you hear parents being like sounds
like you're having some big feelings yes
and I'm gonna give you some space you
know what I mean I'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah your parents
apologizing more unheard of again no in
the 80s yeah don't crack that veneer no
my mom my mom apologized I began
apologizing once she went to school for
uh she became a marriage and family
therapist and then she started
apologizing and I love my mom's
apologies were blanket it was sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry
[Laughter]
it's also you know being a mom you never
win or a parent I'm sure you just you're
never gonna win the game and so you just
yeah keep it uh keep it coming but to
frame it that way that's a way to win
that's how I would explain it to my
parents I'd be like it's like the power
struggle is over I don't live with you
and now you could really knock out of
the park with a very simple like you
know
I never meant to ever scare you or make
you uncomfortable I do that you ever
make yourself cry doing an impression of
your parents is that your father that's
my father it's a great impression oh
[Laughter]
they're bad Eights
[Music]
I just mean some you know sometimes you
see an 80 that's like Jack LaLanne you
know oh God yeah some people like
pull-ups really killing it they're not
going to pull up 80s yeah my dad the end
was uh he turned to volunteer around
town and nobody will hire me because
they said I will fall over yeah I'm a
liability yeah yeah yeah which is
[__] hire everybody everybody gets
to be [__] at everything like like let
them be [__] yeah
you all get to participate come on it's
way better than falling alone it's true
exactly you're gonna be
visible fall at Ace Hardware and that's
where we found him he had fallen at home
um he had gotten what he got in kovid
had been out and about with his his
girlfriend Mary uh having a great time
but um
I'm a dad I don't even know your dad but
of course he was out with Mary yeah they
were having a hoagies and um
yeah he had some covid uh got some covet
and then uh that Tech mod of the game
but I think the reason he uh the covet
hit him so hard was because he had this
late in life and I don't know if this is
a thing but I've heard from other people
uh dementia anorexia where it's like he
got very Karen Carpenter in the past two
years of his life was saying oh I'm not
gonna put out a new weight you know I'm
not going to be he got very fat phobic
like look at he pointed it poked in my
dad my my husband's stomach and said
okay he put on a couple pounds what's
happening like that's the control
fantasy am I right yeah yeah I always
say where is your anxiety pooling oh you
know what he was like it's like Mercury
it's like little drops of mercury and
sometimes it just like the gravity goes
and it all goes to like am I at my ideal
weight yeah dysmorphia or this or the
number the number yeah blue is it this
number oh God beloved number well in the
sense that the unhealthy part of us
likes obsessing it like fixing I was
having a mild fixation today where I was
trying to text the special thanks for my
credits uh for the credits of my new
special so I'm pasting it in the email
nice and it's sent and then I was like
oh no
um I forgot one name I add it and then I
paste it again and of course in the
email it's now shrunk it to like an
ellipses you ever see where it like goes
like well you sent this twice so we're
gonna eliminate it and it's just the the
name I added and I'm like and then you
and I know you know because you're so
open about this is anxiety what we're
talking about is anxiety I don't know
yeah is that right
um Sorry my phone's being wonky I I and
then I text it to my friend the full
list and I go can you email this to the
list he does it Maria I open it it's
been truncated to Three Dots and two
names oh no and I go and I start writing
hey everybody just so you know the list
isn't two names and then I stop and I go
this is anxiety and then I delete it and
I just let it be and then 20 minutes
later I just go just so you know the
full list is about 39s you just got to
make sure like I I wouldn't say I lost
but that's where my anxiety happened to
be pooled it wasn't even about that it
was just like it's [__] crazy to be
here so your dad was pulling it on yeah
wait wait and I this broke my heart is
when we uh went to his house uh when he
was in the hospital and the book he had
open on his couch was the mindful way
through depression by John cabotson
never being mindful during your
depression there's no reason not
the flat end of a shovel as my friend
Jackie says like there is no need no
you're saying when your mind has become
an unsafe neighborhood you don't want to
follow your breath and just kind of walk
around with no flashlight I
mean I tried I tried I thought that was
monstrous uh when I went uh yeah I was
in a Outpatient Treatment thing for a
couple times and they keep giving us
this book which is called David Burns
um I believe it's called change your
mind change your life or something like
that and it's all things where it's like
cognitive behavioral switches like I you
know I'm depressed or what if I have the
feelings that are depressed like right
like just it's like yeah it doesn't
matter there's a razor in my head that's
vibrating like I I'm not taking in any
of this nonsense it's funny when we I
quote that all the time ramdas said that
too which is like ins and I do it yeah
but I I have to check my sort of um
mental health privilege I suppose and
I'm not trying to be funny meaning it
works for what I'm dealing with yes I'm
having like a down in the dumpster on my
scale sure and I go you know it helps me
a little bit to go there is depression I
see it I'm not going to identify with it
but you're saying you know there's a
level that's way way
here on the knife's edge or whatever for
years and some people you know going
through having to do uh where you get
ECT therapy or or whatever or people
genuinely going through daily trauma or
you know people are unhoused like it's
just like
[__] you like little mental games yes
don't work don't yeah aren't and it's
annoying when someone just goes like
maybe just uh yeah and you're talking to
someone who does again I try to always
say like this is just kind of for like
your everyday little yeah whatever is
that helps me but like so you're talking
to someone who does say that sometimes
yeah yeah and yet I'm very interested in
what you're saying this difference
there's a there's a there's another
League
but there's another another level and I
think I you know I'm I'm definitely yeah
I am definitely privileged I have uh all
the meds and uh and all the health care
which is still I I was like you know
just like don't be surprised if mental
health care or any health care is shitty
it's not your fault don't take it
personally and everybody's struggling to
maintain their you know like like you're
just not gonna get the greatest even if
you have a [__] ton of money to throw at
it I once paid three grand for uh three
days in a um it's called last encinas in
uh they told me I could I stopped I was
there because I was like oh I'm suicidal
and I I just uh need a place to get my
meds checked out and they I thought my
insurance covered it but as soon as I
was in they said oh yeah no it doesn't
and they'd already taken away my purse
but I said well you're gonna have to get
the purse out uh because they would only
take cash which I think is so funny
um that one of the signs of mania is to
send spend irrational amounts of money
on something that's useless and uh wow
so it's not it's not great I went to a
friend who's uh have a friend who's
unhoused um we went through the
currently yeah unhoused I've known a
comedian for 30 years and
um yeah I think just this situation
circumstances are very it is very easy
to lose your housing and uh yeah so we
went to the Department of Social
Services here in Los Angeles uh spot uh
this time was about an hour and a half
wait which is pretty delightful actually
I was surprised uh went through all the
um to the different dwarves on the way
to the troll into the bridge and who's a
lovely man named Robert now Robert
Robert looked Robert sorry Robert's job
is so difficult and he could barely make
eye contact with it with us as he was
telling this he's like yeah there's no
there's no housing and I was like wow I
thought that was the case but thanks for
letting us know and then they mean like
uh well there's no one word for the
housing like Help Housing there's no
emergency there's nothing there's
nothing so you're back on the street and
um and so all right my friend you know
lives lives in a car situation and
um so all right no so then uh Robert
said well there is something but it's a
pilot program oh my God okay what what
is it
so it only you have to sign up through
another agency it was another thing that
involved
um about 30 mile drive through to Los
Angeles which is as we all know uh like
asking someone to go to a Singapore via
Nairobi what's going on is there a
purpose to this and then uh so we found
out what that was he said yeah it
provides 400 towards housing all right
um what housing will take this 400 he
said I don't know
well thanks Robert it's been a great
afternoon wow
um and this that's kind of like and I
think that kind of trauma is happening
every single day you know I just that
mindfulness is not gonna do that like
yeah to go hey you know as you feel the
110 degree of heat on your uh on your
brow as you're waiting uh for something
that will not be available
uh let's just breathe in through the
nostrils and out through the mouth
anyways uh and I see that saying I you
know I I have not done you know to help
my friend Beyond being there with her
and you know have tried to do uh you
know pay for uh hotels and stuff like
that uh but then it's like yeah there's
no solution there's no solution Beyond
yeah so wow wow you know this is sort of
a right turn I I appreciate all of all
of that and the one of the
topics that came up in your album
speaking of anxiety speaking of
difficulty was um Debtors Anonymous
which I didn't know anything about
what is it Google any problem and you
can find a solution it could be an
anonymous program but um it could be
anything else I gotta tell you googling
is so powerful
um so powerful
Million results you type it in point
zero zero two seconds later you got
Summoners of debt you got a problem with
dead Maria Bamford struggles with that
one of the best what are the best what
does it mean what does it mean it's
basically it's and this is one person
speaking about it so I apologize to all
my friends who get mad at me wait not
even the program before you before you
[__] on the prime
what is the issue that the program is
addressing debtors well I think the idea
it
believe this program started in the 80s
which starts around the time that Things
become uh or will credit cards become
more of a marketed situation so there's
that it's also something that happens uh
okay so these are people that can't stop
spending yes shopaholic is the could
could be that but it can be anything so
like AAA I don't know if you've known
anybody who is in uh the Bill W program
uh Bill Wilson we all know his last name
um who books that who books that well it
turns out it's hard to get it's hard to
get up at some of those meetings in West
Hollywood
um yeah you'll have to uh Brad P we have
Brad P for Sunday so
um
anyways
uh the great thing about 12-step
programs I love them they're free number
two free number three they cannot kick
you out that's one of their main rules
uh so and also another great rule that
they have is um and they're all
individualized so they're not all under
one thing but they're pure it's all run
by peers so nobody's in charge
um and that's also delightful though
terrifying and
um my husband I brought him to a meeting
he said these people need professional
help yes yes they do and yet not as
forthcoming and so here we are in this
Zoom breakout room but uh yeah so it's
great it's also problematic it's was
started in the 30s so it's got
pseudo-spiritual sort of judeo-christian
language it's a real turn off for
anybody who is raised uh in a religion
oh my God but what I do and uh I ignore
ignore all that and I just
tends to me that I like what was if you
don't mind
which is eye contact I like eye contact
yes I like hearing other people's
stories of people trying to do something
different that's somewhat more healthy
like I like harm reduction like oh my
God I can't stop whatever it is I can't
stop taking heroin well can you have a
pizza along with that heroin why don't
you eat a whole pizza and then do the
heroin like yeah like let's just yeah it
doesn't have to be perfect
um
so for me I went because I did I just
didn't know uh I lived in Minneapolis I
was 20 until I was 24 and I just did not
know how to have and keep a job I just
didn't I moved to Los Angeles I was and
what was the compulsive behavior that
was tied to that I think just asking for
money from my parents that was the yeah
which was like and they were like yeah
no you're we're done and uh and I think
it is a product of living in a city or a
society or an economic system that it
doesn't provide
um social welfare so I think that's part
of the reason D.A is a thing in the U.S
London uh South Africa you know it's
like it's only it happens in certain
major cities it's interesting you know
that it's a big deal there and what did
it look like when you weren't able to
keep a job
um well I worked at very uh I had a
degree in English and uh despite that
not that these aren't great jobs but I
would take a job
um where I would I was waitressing which
I was terrible at I am I really started
strong but no no not even the first
hello I do not give off the vibe that
everything's gonna be okay which is what
which is what you want in a server yeah
your table is at a lot of like chatter
like I don't think it's coffee yeah no
and they were correct
um so when I moved to Los Angeles I
could not keep a waitering job because
people are at a professional level here
nobody's having it nobody's like no it's
okay if I didn't get my side of kale
with a with a lemon on this but a full
lemon and you know what to charge me for
a whole lemon you know that's on the
that's on the
on the menu and I'm a whole lemon
um
like you belonged in like a quaint like
a small town yeah exactly people are
sucking it up people are like well this
is a theme it's cold but she's trying
your Dad should be allowed to suck and
fall these these groups should be able
to run themselves even if there are
things that suck like we're we're like a
suckless society yeah yeah and it's not
really working because we don't have
room for the broken or the or the
learning and I love I love broken I love
an open mic night I'm going to one
tonight 9 p.m not to say the people that
open mic nights I know I'll say that but
I as one who wins yeah and as one who
would go yes there's a Brokenness great
they're so great well you're drawn to
humanity yeah I love to see something
I've never seen before like oh my God
someone's nude and crying where are we
going with this there's only three
minutes left I can't wait
like I'm mean I I love something well
crafted I really appreciate and I love
comedy
um but I also yeah I appreciate someone
trying like trying I want to see I don't
want to see someone yawning on stage
saying
um what else am I going to talk about
[__] [__] you like
figure it out
that's like something you've thought
about
day long yeah
um but and I don't know why they're
wearing so much yeah
goddamn swearing yeah this is wonderful
I I really relate to what you're saying
and it's the same with conversation and
stuff that's why I was like I feel like
you'll enjoy this podcast it's like
let's get into it let's find that thing
that's that's that well and I I think
that 12 12 especially I just had nowhere
else to go I couldn't make my rent
I was renting from this place that the
landlord accepted sex for rent according
to the teenage runaways who were next
door to me and I was like hey now I also
had like five thousand dollars in
medical debt because I had a I got an
STD and I went to I let it get so bad
that I went to
um Planned Parenthood which was in
Hollywood and my STD was so bad that
they said why did you let it get
this far and I was like why did you let
it win yeah
and I was like wow I mean you have to
let it get bad yeah
it's like yikes yeah like and you're the
12th person I've seen today with this
yeah it's not so unabated but yes can
you even think I don't want this this
looks like you were encouraging it
mentally did you put some plantings up
there what's going on is that fertilized
um but yeah so I had been another
post-tip program I've been an Overeaters
Anonymous for about five years at the
time because I had been bulimic what a
white woman
I've lost interest in my own narrative
sorry does that tie to your dad
um possibly I think my dad might have
been the source but I think he put it
through my mom because my mom was the
only one who ever got freaked out about
diets and food my dad never said
anything uh but I really she made a bit
been parroting some stuff that he was
saying but without saying it was from
him because my dad never said anything
about it to us but as soon as she died I
was like oh my God it's become from this
guy the whole time oh wow um wow so uh
yeah very weird but sorry you were you
were saying you you had oh you went to
Overeaters oh yeah so I was like okay I
had a sponsor who said yeah you're not
making enough money to live on uh
because I I worked at a
uh Bakery loading trucks at night in L.A
because that's the job I could I could
had the confidence and that's a great
job but the guys around me who are all
Spanish-speaking you know who are like
this they all call me uh onion face
and they um one guy who's really onion
face were you always crying because I
got a big white round face
either red onions maybe after a few
weeks in the sun they'll call you Red
Onion fish big white round face
um
[Music]
oh my God that's so good
um
uh yeah those guys were like what what
are you doing like they they were
questioning My Life Choices the guys
were like why are you here loading
trucks
um yeah you speak English what are you
doing and I uh yeah so I went to what is
the answer there well only because there
is I'm noticing my own privilege bias
you have two parents Minnesota two
parents in Minnesota yeah and there
wasn't like uh a cushion or no yeah I
just thought this is a great idea I'm
gonna move and then you couldn't wait
tables because that wasn't working yeah
it just wasn't working and those two
yeah so I thought I also like solitary
positions so loading trucks was great I
do like physical work so I was like this
is awesome but then it wasn't making
enough money it doesn't it doesn't pay
uh enough to live on as we all have read
in The Economist and so uh and everyone
knows who has a job so um
so then I went to Daddy's Anonymous and
what it is just like any group of people
if you farm out an idea to five people
at a diner or wherever you go they'll go
what are you doing and then five people
have ideas and so they were like wait so
what what other skills do you have and I
was like well I guess I can I can type
and I can uh you know I have an English
degree and they're like
sign up at 10 temp agencies I did that I
called them every I became willing as a
part of people's support said call every
single day tell them you're available
for work for temp agency and I was like
but I don't know how to answer phones
they're like you'll figure it out yeah
and but all I did genuinely need that
human support of like yeah I don't know
how to do something and I still do
that's why I really like places like
that I I don't know I mean I did a book
deal I did not read the contract I did I
still don't know how to live life
properly and I and I think that's where
I get myself in trouble is like going oh
somehow I I should be prideful and and I
should know how to do this that's where
I get myself in a pickle because I I
think you don't necessarily have to go
to a professional you to slow yourself
down and go
hey I'm thinking of signing this book
deal should I read it yeah yeah Maria
why don't you read it out loud let's
have
ham let's have a juice box read it out
loud and see what you're signing
yourself up for instead of just going
what
this is awesome
then what I ended up doing is I gave my
whole advance to an editor because I was
so frightened I was so frightened that I
didn't know how to write a book so I get
the whole Advance which fine it's okay
he was lovely but also gave the advance
back No I gave the advance to an editor
an outside Editor to help me write the
book because I was so afraid that I
couldn't write a book or that I wouldn't
do a good job which is all about fear
Terror uh where did you Craigslist no no
no no I found a guy who happily take
your Advance this guy who uh yeah great
guy no and deserved every penny I'm a
pain in the ass yeah so it was great but
had I slowed it down I might have said
hey Maria why don't you pay half of the
you know half of the advance to him pay
half to yourself so you don't have to be
touring the whole time also if I had
read the contract I would have known uh
more specifically uh
when the book when I'm done with the
book I don't get to decide that the
publisher decides whether they think
it's done or not so if they don't think
it's done I need to pay that money back
if they reject it which in a sense I may
have
um taught myself a lesson but that I
need to I owe somebody 50 Grand to find
out that I didn't want to write a book
you know what I'm saying like it is a
debt on some level because you lost you
could have lost the advance and then
owed the advancement yes yeah so had I
slowed that down and and that's not what
happened it's it's worked out fine but I
really love the idea of it I don't
always do it obviously I didn't do it in
this but is to
crowdsource other ideas well what I'm
loving about what you're saying is
there's something beautiful about get
and I'm using the word broken and
including myself yeah yeah broken people
there's there's this quote that keeps
coming to mind if we despise our own
Brokenness we tend to despise the broken
and I think we see that a lot and people
discard people and if I were making a
little short film about this some of
these stories you've been telling is how
you keep going to imperfect places and
getting help
and isn't that beautiful well yeah I um
I have a Kickstarter that I did because
I wanted to do uh this thing about OCD
that's you know it's it's not a topic
for everybody web series I watched it oh
do you have just two sets it's
incredible yeah too little it's so well
done thank you and you're so it's called
oh no no sorry
sorry it's so good all of this and I I I
I slowed it down because I was like I
started to get this manic like I'm gonna
do 17 episodes in one month and I'm
gonna send everyone champagne and then I
had a meeting with two with two people
in my dinner everyone gets champagne you
know when you like have these like crazy
ideas I don't have bipolar but I get
manic as well and I just have to go no
promises today yeah or I'm gonna give
everyone everything yeah just let it go
let it go let it go is a good one I
talked to two people in my Debtors
Anonymous group one guy is a um
meditation teacher the other person
builds furniture and I said to these
guys we had french fries I bought the
french fries at this place called
Everest Burger in my neighborhood where
only the French phrase are very good
no Avast Burger on Lake Avenue go
altitina
anyways great and
um they were like hey can you do 17
episodes one and I was like
and they're like how many do you think
you can do and I was like maybe three
they're like well what if it was the
best of all possible world so I ended up
doing a Kickstarter which is
under the auspices of slow business I do
three only three episodes over an
undisclosed amount of time I paid
everyone including myself uh Union level
wages so for their time and uh yeah and
also there's so there's no and also no
um rewards everyone no matter how much
you got got Democratic rewards back
which is
built-in disappointment with me uh you
get to the feeling of like oh I was
really let down by Marie Bamford that's
yours that's yours to keep you mean AD
Revenue yeah is that what you're talking
about splitting out of Revenue no no no
no no no no no no what are we talking
about uh just Kickstarter it was a
Kickstarter so it was did any well what
are you saying Democratic rewards what
are the rewards that are being
Democratic starter usually you have to
give like people go like oh you gave one
dollar I'll send you a sticker oh you
gave it 100 I'll have dinner with you
the donators got rewards they only give
ten thousand dollars oh I'll I'll make
out with you in a public place yeah
whatever it is and so I said it's
private yeah plenty private
um but uh yeah this I said I don't
everyone gets the same amount no matter
how much you give and uh and then that
also made it I didn't have to be worried
about all these rewards that I'd owe
people yeah and um yeah raised plenty of
money to do these three episodes I and
it was such a much more joyful way of
doing it yeah I'm excited
um I'm also you're very Democratic in
your style these groups and these people
in your life it fits you yeah well yeah
but I wouldn't have done that had I not
met with two other people who knew
nothing about Show Business who are just
just going like
that kind of sounds kind of stressful
why don't you do something less why
don't you do less than what you're
thinking yeah yeah yeah that's right it
doesn't doesn't have to be a trained
professional or someone in your field to
recognize a human overextension yeah
it's very normal we all do it and I
think that that that's
I don't like that stuff where it's like
do you have a do you have a business
coach it's like do you just have someone
you could talk the Barista yeah at
Starbucks so you could go hey what do
you think about what I'm doing I'm
thinking of making these cups uh that uh
at my home okay I'm making cups okay I'm
killing cups in my stove I'm charging
hotter bucks for them like
um you know like just crowdsource it
like also with mental health stuff like
because
if you have Kaiser Permanente you're
gonna see even if you've had a terrible
trauma you've been almost murdered and
raped or what and fully raped and I hate
sorry that's a trigger warning that I
said that I'm sorry uh but they will uh
only see you once every six weeks like
there's no the it's such a gaslighting
by uh mental health things where they go
hey you ask for help you know all these
little memes it's like right from
[__] where where yeah
um or or you ask for help and it's not
the greatest and I'm not saying that
that you won't find wonderful therapists
and stuff like that I just don't want
people to feel like an idiot when you
because I felt like oh there's something
wrong with me it wasn't easy it isn't
that it isn't the greatest can I ask you
about the series
boy I hope this isn't an annoying
question but it looks like it might help
it helps me oh good when I watch your
video it made me feel a little bit more
comfortable oh good because we all know
what it's like I'm not trying to trauma
compare or mental illness compare I'm
just saying you might think those videos
are like this is so weird
um and I'm watching it going like yeah I
know what it's like when your mind takes
over and you get away from yourself so
it suited me does it soothe you in
making it yes yes
and I know that I'm now OCD and go to
the ilcdf foundation
um interaction
International OCD Foundation they have a
lot of free resources groups all sorts
of wonderful things online free
everything's free
um uh but there's a lot more information
out there about intrusive thoughts about
very taboo subjects and so whatever you
think is Taboo in your culture that's
what where OCD is going to get you yeah
so things like pedophilia people have
fear um that's a very common thing for
people to have a fear that they're gonna
their pedophiles or something even
though they desperately don't want to
never what I think is unique and
interesting about some of your phobias
is like you're afraid you might hurt
somebody yes it's actually
it's sort of weird to say that a phobia
could be lovely but at least it's sort
of like Earnest and sweet well and it's
something out of uh maybe religion
religious traditions of people who pray
without ceasing a lot of those Saints
we're dealing with unwanted thoughts
like saying oh my God I'm having this
thought again oh I can pray I'll pray I
pray pray keep praying make it go away a
lot of people have religious obsessions
fear that they've thought of something
sacrilegious
um that's very common blasphemy
blasphemy
um women with postpartum depression and
and known women that had babies that
their fear was hurting the baby yeah and
I've had it this is weird but to relate
I've had the fear
um I don't know if it changes it that I
was stoned but I was stoned and I was
like oh my God I'm the biggest threat to
me yeah like I'm the one that like keeps
doing like driving and flying and you
know eating fatty stuff like it's me it
was like there was this other thing
going like you're the threat and I was
like you're right and I was like but it
sucks I'm in charge and it was like I
know like it was a real weird
conversation so I I relate to the call
that's coming from inside the house
right it's you right yeah no well that's
a common one fear that you're gonna kill
yourself
um or um yeah so I it is much I think
there's a lot of it more info
information on Tick Tock and and uh
Instagram and stuff that you can look up
about these issues nothing funny but
Tick Tock looks like unwanted thoughts
maybe sometimes yeah like it's just like
she had to hyper cut ones in the it's
like Japanese energy drinking yeah I'm
like what is this like whenever I see
someone on Tick Tock I have a real hard
time not being like yikes or whatever
whoever they're following I don't know
if it's the whole platform but a lot of
it seems like a like like a like it's
hypnotizing you or something yeah yeah
and there's and I I yeah I know that but
I know that there are some positive
things that are coming out of it that
people are getting education stuff for
sure great and um I know that I had some
experiences when I told somebody about
my intrusive thoughts of I don't know if
you've ever told a therapist and then
paid them 75 dollars uh to call the cops
uh because they called the cops on you
yeah because and the cops didn't come
because we're in Los Angeles and uh but
you told them you were having some sort
of yeah
and which is different it's not a
fantasy I mean also I want to say that
anybody who's having fantasies of
hurting someone or you know molesting or
whatever like that that deserves just as
much [__] help as anything else uh
please let's have people talk about this
I wish uh I wish one of the saddest I
mean not only uh the
the actual assaults themselves but like
I wish some of the comedians the the
unregistered sex offenders out there
would address what's going on in their
minds it's about this material like
in your act like what is happening like
this is the perfect opportunity
especially I mean as opposed to acting
like nothing happened acting like
nothing happened and or saying oh I went
through sex addiction now I'm okay well
talk about it like people are having
this problem and like this is that's all
that comedy is for yeah it's like it's a
bad thing and that's all we want to know
it's just a bad behavior we don't want
to talk about like the steps that led
there the the the shame that led there
the isolate the internal isolation that
only encouraged it and then yeah sexual
assault is happening on the regs uh you
know domestic violence uh you know
pedophilia all the child pornography
like if you're caught doing it would you
please do us the favor of talking about
it like in saying what's in in that
comes from recovery or something like I
I don't want to talk about any of our
shadows yeah it's not you just mentioned
the Heavy Hitters yeah yeah we don't we
really as a society don't want to it's
good and bad and and we don't one of our
coping strategies as as a people is like
don't don't even look at it well like if
the bet I mean I don't know and that's
one thing I do love about 12-step
programs is I do love the living amends
of like
if you know if you've done some shitty
things number one stop bugging the
people don't bother the people that you
hurt anymore don't make direct amends to
them be a better person make amends in
the and I say this to myself as well
because I'm I'm not the greatest uh and
I'm sure uh yeah I I continue to make
mistakes I know uh my current album has
uh the first joke about it where this
somebody said that um when I say I'm
identifying as a little man uh because
uh I'd like to get paid better and
somebody spoke you know said hey that's
actually that joke is is transphobic and
which I now I totally see what they're
saying but I you know I'm an old lady I
did not see the time and I need to
apologize you know and all I can do is
change the joke like now change the joke
and say you know the materials out there
uh
yeah change the joke and shut up you
know uh so yeah
that's interesting yeah I I understand
it's just it's it's a tricky subject
well well and it's I don't have I don't
want to hurt anybody's feelings I want
to respect everything and I understand
well and I don't have a dog in the fight
so why am I using that as a punchline
yeah why am I using I mean if I'm gonna
say oh I I would like to uh I'm uh the
joke is you know
um I don't want to be a part of any
group
um you know I'm a woman but am I if I'm
going to be paid less than Greg yeah no
that I am I am I am not I'm not a woman
I am now a man I am I'm a little man I'm
a little man I'm a rich little man which
that's better than identify which I
think you just sort of fix that yeah
fixed it yeah well I think I fixed it
let me know
uh I don't think you have to worry
Instagram me DM I listen I'll read all
my DMs especially specials that are mad
oh boy yeah are you sure about that yeah
yeah sure I'm because I would like to
learn I I would definitely I find it
good to to learn Jesus Christ if anyone
takes time out of their day to tell me
hey
this bothered me and here's why like
thank you thank you
um you know some things I I don't
necessarily like I don't agree with
somebody got mad at me about talking
about 12 step groups in any critical way
and I I disagree with that like I think
I have over 30 years of experience in it
I've had very negative experiences in
Foster programs along with it I do feel
it saved me you know saved my life but
that the guy totally texted me or
tweeted at me and said hey you know you
shouldn't make jokes about Telstra
programs that saved my life you bum me
up oh and you disagreed and I said yeah
I disagreed and or I say I totally see
how that would hurt your feelings I'm
very sorry
um and and I am sorry that because I
understand how that would feel very
hurtful at the same time I get to have
my own experience I get to
um
because I've also uh yeah I get to have
my own experience yeah for sure which I
have that with my family my sister you
know has told me numerous times not to
do impersonations of her and yet I've
said I love you so much and also she
says some pretty hilarious things
she's also written about me and her
books so I go
well well I hear you I hear that pain
and and acknowledge it and say I you
know I think yeah she's a shaman and a
life coach yeah yeah yeah yeah and and
that stuff I I mean you couldn't have
asked for a if I listened to your comedy
and I was like
it would be great if she had a sister
who was a shaman or like like if I
didn't know that I would be like that
would be perfect and I want to
acknowledge that that that's very
vulnerable to be publicly to say uh
she's also blonde blue-eyed Shaman uh
wow she's taken a hit from all sides in
terms of
she's very sincere which is not my gift
uh I do not uh I just want to say I'm
kind of on the fence about everything
really Maria
um
but I yeah
so she's our yeah she's vulnerable so uh
but I I let me see my current joke about
her was uh oh she wrote me an
affirmation
um Maria okay this one's for your job
how is it my fault they hired me
um so that's something to remember like
when you're on set or something yeah
yeah how is it my fault they hired me
it's not my I had nothing to do with
this debacle oh my God
what she is she's super my sister's very
funny and she's super extroverted too
which
um which is why I must compete with her
to our dying day
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at magicmind you're always
hearing me offering magic mind to the
guests why because I drink it every
single episode and when my guests drink
it I feel like we have a better
conversation because it lights up our
brains gives you about as much caffeine
as half of a cup of coffee but also
gives you adaptogens it has like lion's
mane mushroom incredibly very
meticulously formulated formula
formulated formula I like that so it
calms you down a little bit it's great
when you take it with your coffee but it
also has new atropics that help you
think focus and concentrate and it just
rounds out the caffeine experience I
find it wonderful I personally take it
with coffee a lot of people take it
instead of coffee sweetened with agave
it's not gonna spike your blood sugar
it's not like a sugary energy drink it's
very natural it's matcha it's wonderful
it's like Creator raid athletes have
Gatorade Magic Mike is creatorade with a
mix of 12 functional ingredients it
doesn't get you wired it doesn't get you
jittery gets you dialed in helping you
slip into that flow state for about five
to seven hours getting about 30 percent
more productivity more things done after
you drink it fighting off
procrastination fighting off brain fog
and fatigue and some ADD symptoms
getting you into that sweet spot to get
work done if I'm gonna write I'm going
to do stand up if I'm going to answer
emails and they have a money back
guarantee so any first purchase will be
refunded no questions asked if it
doesn't meet your uh the weirdos
expectations that's you guys I have
never introduced a friend to it and not
had them love it and be blown away so we
have a special offer for weirdos and our
friends at Magic mind all you have to do
is go to
www.magicmind.co weird and use my
discount code at checkout weird to get a
20 off your first order that's
magicmine.com weird and use discount
code weird support your noodle support
the show it means a lot
or also did you know were also brought
To Us by Blue land I'm jumping right
into the the fun fact did you know we're
eating and drinking roughly a credit
card's worth of plastic a week when I
first heard that I was like maybe in a
year a week that's right the products
that we're using every day are
ultimately contaminating our water
supply generating hundreds of
microplastics that we end up barf
ingesting luckily our friends at Blue
land have set out to do something about
it to eliminate the need for single-use
plastic in the products we reach for the
most like hand soap did you know there
is an estimated 5 billion plastic hand
soap and cleaning bottles thrown away
each year 5 billion and if that's not
bad enough most cleaning formulas are 90
water which is heavy ship which leads
excessive carbon emissions it's a total
waste not to mention the nasty
ingredients in them like chlorine and
ammonia but blue land is Reinventing
cleaning Essentials to be better for you
and the planet by offering endlessly
refillable cleaning products with a
beautiful cohesive design that I love it
looks great on encounter and I like that
everything matches just fill the bottles
with water drop in the tablets and wait
for them to dissolve hand soap toilet
bowl cleaner laundry tablets all with
clean ingredients you can feel good
about and no more bulky Cleaning
Supplies on your grocery run best of all
refills start at just two dollars and 25
cents I recommend their clean Essentials
kit which has everything you need to get
started and comes in beautiful light
scents such as Iris Agave fresh lemon
and Eucalyptus mint and blue land has an
offer just for weirdos get 15 off your
first purchase of any product and get
cleaning products that I love the look
of and love that they're good for you
and they're good for the planet to get
15 off your first order go to
blueland.com
ymiw like you made it weird you won't
want to miss this blueland.com ymiw
that's blueland.com
ymiw alright guys let's get back to it
my sister's very funny and she's super
extroverted too which um which is why I
must compete with her to our dying day
let me ask you going back only because
I'm fascinated it's not just a stock
question you moved to LA
where did the where was that first
impulse as a child that you're like
Showbiz I I can see obviously you're
made of talent and and expression is
natural to you but when you were a
little kid like how old were you when
you were like that's for me
and then
I I'd love to hear all of the origins I
love attention I love I mean I think
John Mulaney said it at the end of his
and it was current special baby Jay he
said uh now I'm fine I don't need drugs
or alcohol or whatever but uh all I need
is all the attention and uh I could
relate with that
um yeah those three I started playing
the violin as a kid and uh Suzuki method
and that felt great getting up on stage
I didn't really enjoy playing the violin
but I love the feeling of being watched
Yeah by a group and then being applauded
yeah uh which is all that happens when
you're three years old and you play a
musical instrument nobody's booing at
that point yeah it's when you get in
your 11s and 12s where they start going
oh
come on you've been at this
you know at this for nine years now kid
um
[Applause]
[Laughter]
your mother and father have put in
lesser money into this
um yeah uh but that's very young did it
come from some sort of deficit or a lack
or was it just kind of a natural pure I
think I mean I like it but my mom and my
sister were very talkative so they were
chatty Cathy's also
um they're likable people my parents my
sister and my mother were very they're
likable personalities whereas I was a
bit of a glum Gus a bit of a sour apple
a bit of the Weeping
there's a picture of me at the beach
where I'm like
which is not unlike a face that I just
made a few days ago
um
my husband is this your face yeah
yeah and asked did they did the dogs
poop when he took a mohawk and I said
poop's a billion sort of like in a rage
like uh who's it for civilian who's
afraid of a Virginia wolf like what why
am I in so angry so you didn't like the
beach I I'm I'm understanding this and
it seems like you're observing reality
like you're a bit about lying you're
like this is crazy like people say don't
lie unless it's socially convenient yeah
yeah and like if it's a crowd pleaser
unless it's
philosophy that you're supposedly basing
your entire life on exactly no religion
is a strange place I remember thinking
that as a kid being like just spit it
out I don't think my dad really believes
that you know what I mean or like I
don't think most of these people really
believe so that's a weird cognitive
dissonance so a lot of your comedy seems
to come like we had this line I have
this line that I say that art is highly
sensitive people reporting back to the
group what reality feels like to them
yeah and that seems like a lot of what
you're doing is observing quiet girl at
the beach you don't like it and then
it's bubbling up bubbling up and then it
wants to come out is that correct yeah
yeah and getting attention I think that
that you know if I I definitely started
doing voices when I was like probably
four or five like would watch TV and try
to do different voices because my own
voice was like a high wine I think some
would argue it still is
some Scholars some Scholars Bill Burr
why do I keep does Bill Burr say that I
assume he would Dr Burke no
she's showing Feist Chase yeah
I don't like it
I love him so much and I wish to Christ
that he would like my material but I
know I don't know very well but I got to
no I don't think so because who watches
he's a killer he's he's like did you see
his beautiful friends with bunnies
sometimes
[Music]
did you see his beautiful set when uh uh
in Philadelphia where he turns down the
ground yeah yeah you loved it I love I
watched that every once in a while yeah
just to like you know get that feeling
of like yeah
yeah and do your material
those [__] yes which is the machismo
of Comedy I did always like that because
my dad wanted I think needed a son so
that was part of I always liked I think
or have some pride about being like I
don't [__] need anything I don't need
anything and also being around guys and
handling myself I thought I was very
proud prideful about about that like
when did Steelers show up when did that
your first time um
I was in college yeah I was in college
they had a talent night and I did you
write a little room yes I wrote a little
routine you wrote it up yeah did you
rehearse it yeah of course I did yeah
in the shower in the mirror uh I don't I
think I'd really was
yeah I would do things to I think I did
it while walking because I I don't think
I had any private time I had lots of
Roommates at the time so
um
but uh yeah and I used props I think for
the first three years of doing stand-up
I did a lot of props and I had my violin
uh in probably the first five years and
then I moved to Los Angeles and there
were two other women playing the violin
in their acts and I said to myself this
is my chance
to dodge this violin wow you're watching
another violin act and being like is
that what I look like well no and she
knows she was good like I was just like
oh [__] yeah yeah time to slowly back
yeah back away from the nonsense and
yeah because I think I only use the
violin as a like something like a
people-pleasing thing of like oh well
she's good at that right you know like
what was the style of your first time
going on stage was it voices no the same
exact stuff I do know exactly really
exactly the same okay all right
was it well received
well I I must have felt it was yeah
because I kept doing it yeah
and I keep doing it well that's the
thing the first thing I wrote down on
this little well I haven't looked at it
once but reluctant comedian one of the
things I love about you is there's a
certain
and I feel this too misfittedness
meaning if you like being given
attention and you like being funny and
you like writing jokes and you even like
other stand-up comedy specials the path
to doing stand up is and remains
millions of things that are deeply
unpleasant and not necessarily right for
the gentle creative spirit this person
yeah wouldn't you say like you reference
it all the time like having to lunch in
gigs and or like some Casino gig where
you're bombing well I try to avoid those
gigs at all costs I am now uh refusing
to do one more benefit there's no reason
I'm hurting people yeah at this point
the person who hires me is a fan they
have schizophrenia we are mon you know
eyeball I see you people they're trying
to get money from are Napa Valley Winos
the person who brings me up is going to
be wonderful it's gonna be yamini
Cassandra she's gonna say before
bringing up is everybody ready to have a
good time
I am not a good time I am an assignment
from a therapist I am someone comedians
come at pop in to say huh and I am a uh
someone who can fill a Portland on a
Tuesday night I'm not a good time it's
such a fun thing to know yourself no no
no you're not a big soft bellied man
with a beard that's going to talk about
nachos at the Ballpark versus not just
at Buffalo Wild they what yamanika would
have been great had she just been able
to bring up the headliner Howie Mandel
everybody wants to see Howie Mandel and
that was the proper three-person the
three-person show I bombed so hard and I
just I don't want to do that anymore I
don't want to do that to myself or do
that to other people when you're bombing
are you locked in because one of the
things you're not a real you are
addressing the crowd and how it's going
a little bit but you also are trying to
get on an inner momentum and you're
inviting them along is that correct it's
a theat for me it's a theatrical event
so I'm just doing a show at people like
I that's sort of what I'm saying connect
a little bit like this show was going so
poorly I mean there's no noise and so at
one point even I believe it was 15
minutes in I had a 30 minute set people
started clapping in a way to suggest
they either thought I was done or hoped
I was done uh either which uncomfortable
battering of clapping to like wrap you
up they were giving you the light yeah
and I said I
I'm disappointed as well I thought this
was going to be fun unfortunately I got
15 minutes left and
um I contracted yeah paid and that's
that's even sadder when I'm taking money
from schizophrenia research wow that's
terrible right that's a bad bad look
um while making people suffer uh who
just came to have a good time uh so
anyways we're saying the same thing
right so you're a centrifuge and you're
going into your one-person theatrical
moment and if a few blessed Souls let's
say they don't know who you are but a
few people hook into you and they start
getting it then that spread now you're
murdering you know what I mean that
that's a good Maria Bamford show a bad
one is like nobody can penetrate the
little Tasmanian Devil tornado and then
you're alone there alone everyone's
sucks everyone's alone yeah and I mean
as yamanika said everybody wants to have
a good time yeah including me
um and so I yeah I was a
I I was on a train
um a quiet car with my husband in
Pennsylvania out of Philadelphia a man
was playing The Price is Right at full
volume
and my husband said hey man could you
turn that down this is the quiet car
and this man yelled I'm just trying to
enjoy myself
and I I say that to myself now all the
time I'm just I'm just trying to enjoy
myself
that's what you took from it not Christ
what an [__] but just and that's a
mantra that I've stolen from this
unstable Gruff man well the quiet car is
like dry clean only it's like you gotta
honor that but what if it's the perfect
time in that man's day like yeah this is
the only time he gets quiet
it's not the Price Is Right can't be
let me tell you I spun the wheel once
one time did you and I got a dollar not
on the show backstage okay was it was it
was it hard as it looks I'm going to
tell you something
yeah it's heavy its head right it's very
heavy and I did a little because I'm six
six so it's easier for me I went up a
little and then one spin dollar probably
one of the biggest surges of like joy
that I've ever felt in my life and it
was backstage it wasn't even on the show
it was just hanging out but that I
sense because it's a it's a childhood
thing too it's a childhood thing it's as
close as I'll come to hitting a home run
or something like that it was like it
was that was a home it's a home run for
people who can kind of exert downward
Force that's all I needed to do so so
let me ask you this bombing sucks but
when you killed are you
um I just I had a phone call today and I
was talking about how uncomfortable I
get when I don't perform and and how the
world becomes more and more overwhelming
even even this is a little bit of a
performance it's enough I love being
Amplified uh I assume this is my volume
up yeah and time and I noticed I do that
I'm with you the thing that people might
think would make us anxious is actually
quite calming like I like that we're
being filmed I like that we're being
recorded I'm with you so when you do
really well which you do don't you stop
it you whole lemon
um do you feel where do you put that
feeling on the spinning The Price is
Right is it
lovely but also I think um
and and
also I I think with the the acting as if
I don't want to do well in comedy or I
don't know whatever that I think that's
reluctant or reluctant I just meant
honest like vulnerable You're not going
and going like what's up [__] you're
like I hope this chemistry said I hope
it works I hope it goes well
um but also I know I'll get mad at
people I I get but I can do oh yes you
turn on them yes I've never done this
yes it's uncomfortable it's not good
well that's why I won't watch Bill Burr
as Philly set because I need to watch
things that like calm me down and remind
me to be gentle because believe it or
not I'm pretty close to turning on the
crowd myself no it
what I've been trying to do I took a um
I took a peer specialist training uh for
mental health uh anyways I have to pass
the test so but the point is it's about
um yeah managing uh yeah I'm trying to
use that with the crowd like just like
what does that mean in terms of stuff
like seeing where are people at like if
somebody's heckling or somebody's you
know visibly not enjoying themselves
what's what how did we get here yeah you
know I know why I'm here but there must
be a kind of an interesting story on
your your Voyage to the front row uh
where you're texting thousands of people
you're visibly bored yeah but you
somehow feel like you can't leave yeah
like that's kind of fascinating uh about
your personality or I hear that or uh
and and sometimes it can be like I don't
know it's empathy you're wondering what
is it like to be you yeah and that's
what I this is going to sound crazy but
my wife is always telling me Pete it's
exhausting watching you do comedy for an
hour not in a bad way but when I get a
little mad that at 50 minutes they're
starting to get tired like just that oh
God yeah no even if you're not murdering
just listening to someone for 50 minutes
and I'm like where were you on that one
and it's like [__] it so it's helpful to
have a partner on the outside yeah yeah
just say yeah well that's my yeah my
husband will have a reality check with
me like did I think they gave you a
standing ovation Maria and I'm like yeah
but I don't I always feel like people
there was a delay well I almost feel
like they do a standing Evolution
because they're hoping I won't kill
myself that's what I think oh that's my
reason for it happening but uh which may
be true it's okay I appreciate it you'll
take it however you can get it
but I when oh my dad was always yeah he
would always be sort of like put down
things like you don't have you can't
show the vulnerability of wanting to win
of wanting to do well so like when we
played board games as a kid it'd be like
well I mean who even cares what the
rules are I mean it doesn't I mean if
you really care I guess that's up to you
I just say I don't know why but that
bothered oh no it's awful yeah no I knew
you meant it was awful but I was like oh
yeah no no it's bad especially as
someone like you that was craving
authenticity and humanity and
vulnerability three things that I also
I'm really drawn to the false I was just
just to relate don't forget where we are
I was watching uh alone it's a show
where they're alive all seasons
I love alone it's a metaphor for
everything everything since I've watched
alone I'm like oh my God I have a
metaphor for everything this is like
this this is like how some people do it
this way and some people do it this way
well do you remember kylan Kalyn Kaelyn
it doesn't matter season seven okay she
was great I'm not criticizing the blonde
or that she was a brunette brunette and
she was sensitive she got bit by a
squirrel
um I think no that's there there was a
woman in season seven who continually I
think that was season six who kept
getting bitten and cut okay that woman
that was like an SNL sketch yeah it kept
cutting back to her and she has an ax in
her head and she's like I don't know how
this happened she wounded herself so
much it doesn't matter who kylan or
Kailyn was she just uh couldn't even say
that she wanted to win for women and I
was screaming at the TV saying it's okay
to want to win for women but she was
like I want to win for women not that
women are different from men but because
they're not different from men but they
are but I just want a woman to win not
that oh yeah and I was just going like
it's okay it would be great if a woman
won it's do you see why I brought that
up yes it's similar to being like I
don't even know what the rules are it's
like it's okay just play the game play
the game
well and I think that is maybe something
uh being raised as a girl I don't know
but my husband no for sure she's a
victim in this for sure yeah I was just
trying to he was out of a loving place
going like you're not a bad person for
wanting to be the first woman to win the
show yeah well and I used to play tennis
with my uh friend in in grade school and
we would say sorry
sorry hitting the ball back and forth
apologizing with each not a bit no not a
bit
of women like I hit it I either hit it
too hard for you to get or I hit it and
um yeah or you got it but it was a
little harder that's a heartbreaking
thing that you just said yeah but it's
really
okay finish what you're saying about
your dad and board games and then we
have to talk about alone but oh yeah I
love alone my yeah we'll just Scott so
we've we've played board games before
and um he's very good at Scrabble and
um now I realize how much fun it is
with the rules like to play with the
rules it's fun yeah like we never
learned to play with the rules my dad
would just go let's put the two sets
together and just play on one board
until the board's filled up and then get
then I just go I mean does it really
matter anyways like that is such a
you know what it is I I'm let's take
your dad out of it and just say that it
reminds me of just like a self-center
it's very self-centered inside like a
power it's a power play and it's
familiar yeah when I was a little kid
I'd be like let's play that game when my
friend would be like you always lose
interest and I'd be like I won't this
time and then I would losing interest
and I would as soon as I wasn't winning
it was a it was a computer golf game and
in my mind tell me this isn't this is
like early kind of I'm not saying I have
narcissistic personality disorder but I
was a kid and I was like it's all about
me baby I'm like what if I play the best
anyone's ever played and then as soon as
I'm not now I'm like [__] it up on
purpose and he was just doing it
properly yeah so of course he was
frustrated with me uh I love I I hate
how your dad plays board games no no
and now your husband has has healed that
a little he's healed that well now
we played um I have not played that yet
but I'm sure he knows that one we played
um with aparna nancherla and her sweet
pea Gabe and um and they anyways they
were very they were rocking it and it
was fun I did not realize that playing
game is fun no rules are what make it
fun and so is a clock is what makes it
fun like basketball without a clock is a
nightmare of men
to end it
and they're like we know but there's no
quarters or periods but the truth that's
what Michael Stallone fun is alone is
like it's limits yeah yeah exactly but
you know
you know no they're they're gonna stop
at some time or at least I felt bad
about watching some Seasons where it
became like a snuff film where it was
like oh no what this guy's getting into
he's getting too thin like somebody like
the guy in the was it Argentina where
they were doing the one that was out in
the Patagonia oh no Patagonia yeah yeah
season six there was a guy who got sent
home and he said he was hoarding 22 fish
yeah it got really skinny I know yeah
and and you know you're in trouble when
the Chiron comes up and says something
so there's a guy who's so skinny you're
so worried about him and it says uh
hoarding food is a sign of starvation
yeah isn't that weird isn't there
something like uniquely human about how
we how we break yeah this is what I mean
when I'm saying it's like that's a
metaphor it's like you have food well
that's you have eat it you have to love
yourself you have to say maybe I'll give
myself half the advance like you know
what I mean it's like a similar yeah my
dad well when he got he was getting
depressed after my mom died he lost he
was 5 10 he got to like 130 pounds far
too thin and that's and he would be like
Dad you gotta [__] eat and everyone
was telling to eat eat eat eat eat eat
his girlfriend is bringing over candy
Etc yeah Mary and who loves uh board
games she played this game called
Mexican train I know the name is
problematic but she sure Trans in Mexico
but there certainly are and uh that
people are riding on desperately
um towards who knows and um
I appreciate it
um
she would say well if you're losing what
and you're upset about it you've got to
go on the crybaby room and which was so
fun I went in the crybaby room just to
see what it was like
she was she really was into games I yeah
um shocked that someone said if you're
losing and you don't like it you gotta
go to the cry baby room
to it
I think it was just it was like a room
in the basement
okay this is taking a turn because
that's a scary that's the scariest room
in the house nope I went in it briefly
it was fine it was a choice that you
decorated it with streamers did it say
the crybaby room yeah well I think it's
an emotional place you go to yeah
it's not a metaphor though it is a
physical place
Hail Mary was the best
um oh we're talking about alone
I
I always talk about with my husband of
how long we'd last number one my 10
items would be 10 Hershey's almond
chocolate bars
we just lay down in a bed of leaves yes
bed of leaves yes and just see how long
we last
so funny we've opened we've been
overdoing it I can't hear gilnet
I'm gonna go check my traps I need fat
Apache Dead Fall dead
it is sort of the same thing and I'm
always struck that people don't get
weirder like you would be fun on that
show because you would like once you get
a little that's what I mean I I'm not
trying to make light of I don't know of
mental issues if people take meds I
don't know if they're allowed their
medications they seem like steady Eddies
it's day 100 and they're like well I'm
here in Rock House yeah and uh you know
this was all for my mom
Roland why are you going like my armpits
just to [__] another ass that doesn't
[__] like where was it where was that
where was that I just [__] two stones
dry
I could have wet them like like
one cup joke in like nine Seasons only
one person pooped on like peed or pooped
it was the British lady who was just on
the sheet chest she just peed and said
oh
but yeah there's they really been I
would make it on that I'd make a god day
one yeah like not a real God but like
just a deity I'd make a gun I would make
a Groot like style God and I would be
like and I'd leave it little fish like
I'd do stuff that would make them worry
about me I'm like and I leave a piece of
the fish to Groot and they get well I
made this joke before but they can't
show it because it's Marvel so they blur
it oh
a big labia or something
I'm like screwed but I'd leave
an ish
pray to it if I did if my Gill net was
empty I'd curse it I'd go curse you
Groot
they're very
for people who can live alone it's
editing I also think I wonder if they I
think they spare them
I don't want to know about farting too
because you know there's a lot of a lot
of farting and just for the warmth of it
and how loud yeah yeah come on I thought
it was that fox I can I can do Jordan
from season six as well Jordan was like
I had to go out there and there was like
a bunch uh there's a bunch of snow on
the ground it's a Canadian Native
American voice it was very very
interesting to me that Wolverine stole a
lot of my fat
if anyone
wins you're dying because that's a very
good impression
I went out I killed a moose I shot her
with a blunt arrow and watched it die
over nine hours Pete Holmes gonna be
doing it alone uh tour he's doing a tour
of alone Impressions it's a one-man show
oh my God that would sell out it's a
little sick show I can't figure it out I
think so well I think it's definitely a
niche that you get into yeah
um there's definitely millions of people
that have seen them because they keep
doing it I wouldn't make it I remember
when you got married I forget where we
were maybe New York or something it
doesn't matter but I was like I'm like
your dad does it even matter really all
of my favorite stories
that guy you know he has to roll up a
stone you know up this hill and then it
rolls back down on him and he's just got
to do it again right I mean isn't that
the [__] is your dad alive uh no he
passed away because he I believe part of
it was because of depression and he just
though he stopped eating and he got
covered and he uh he passed away Within
uh probably like 48 hours and it was
just it was so it made me so sad it was
just awful but yeah no I'm sorry too and
um the good thing the good thing was
that we all got to be there with my papi
and he did have those he had some
wonderful hallucinations yeah so he was
like oh there's a breeze off the lake to
shoot a Green Day for a shale
look look it's my cookie club
hey you guys hey you guys I want to play
um my dad had a cookie my dad had a
cookie club when he was a kid what a
cooking club is you get uh your mother
or your you know parent you go hey can
you have all the kids come over once a
week with their parent with a different
kind of cookie and that's called [__]
cookie club and you make that happen
that's something we can do yeah well we
can do that we can do a cookie club
cookie club yeah you ever have a
chocolate chip cookie that has so much
butter in it you're like is this butter
with chocolate chips in it and that's
the best thing you've ever had oh my God
I love that with the salt salt salt
really took us a long time to figure out
salt I think some poor Baker in like the
90s was like put salt on it'll last
longer like which is a preservative and
we've like stumbled into the best
tasting thing it's fantastic I I love
food so much and I can't eat as much of
it as I want uh because then I'd have to
keep buying new pants
and uh that's really it's irritating to
me because I you know I mean this is
this is a topic that has been covered
sweatpants sweat well there's sweatpants
or ruary is are you are you guys
sponsored what's foreign
company that has lots of a loose-fitting
pants that are smooth they smooth your
edges
um also I have a lot of Spanx uh which
they're uncomfortable so they must be
cute
um
yeah
oh they hurt
for a couple of the seasons of crashing
I was wearing Spanx because they were
like it makes you look smoother
it's like oh I'm so sorry I didn't think
that you guys no they do
but I remember being like I guess this
is what it is
I I do look smoother yeah I know it was
uncomfortable they did that to me I
time I got the most enraged and this is
a champagne problem so please uh erase
this from the show if I sound like a
queen when I had my television show
um they would come around and
touch me around my waist tucking in
blouses oh sure and I wanted to howl
yeah from my the depth do not touch me
yeah yeah well I'll join you in in King
griping because the thing when when
crashing was canceled the thing that I
was the most happy about was that people
wouldn't come up and just and they have
to they oh I know but what's the whole
thing here's what I figured out talk
about like mental illness whatever or
neurodivergence is a better way to put
it one thing that I figured out is me
being touched at certain times is
different from other people being
touched and like sometimes Val comes up
and Tenderly cups my face and I'm like
I'm you're putting apple cider vinegar
in my eyeballs right now but I I
actually suppressed that I don't know if
that's healthy but I'll just kind of go
like it's almost over it'll take like I
know she means it lovingly and it's okay
but sometimes I have like that fabric
sensitivity and touch sensitivity and it
really makes you feel like an outcast
that you're like this is but people are
hugging you or something
leading you by the small of your back
yeah stop
you're so good at being sensitive to
people's feelings is because you've
you've wished that for yourself yes it's
empathy yeah and I I would love to be uh
yeah a warm uh pile of softness but I
I'm not and uh it's okay I'm not a good
time I'm not I'm not a good but yeah I'm
having a nice time talking with you well
see you good these these perimeters
you give it parameters you don't seem
like the kind of person who's ever seen
a ghost
um have it my husband says he's seen a
ghost I want to believe him I respect
him but also I'll strike one also I
wonder all right I just go well that's
your experience my sister what is his
goal his whole ghost was in a attic uh
in his neighborhood it was in the garage
of an attic and it was like an old man
and I was like there was probably an old
man living up there but my sister now
that she kept saying something about
food food
and health
get out of here
got it there's a ghost up there and he's
like my name is Reynolds what if the
zombies come no there is a fentanyl
problem there is a genuine fentanyl
problem
the zombies are here the zombies are
here
um my sister yeah my sister sees and you
know has connections and sees with
people yeah and I just oh so she doesn't
like almost like seances like I will
cheetah's Journeys from I know and so uh
yeah totally and I it seems wonderful
like it really gives her guidance and
makes is this her life meeting I mean um
I believe she's done Ayahuasca I don't
want to say that publicly if she doesn't
feel comfortable uh but then the shaman
and a life coach go ahead and assume the
government's like this lady's sipping
the medicine excuse me we had uh a
couple of Vibes yeah yeah a couple of
sips um your parents did Ayahuasca uh no
they turned out they didn't they wimped
out at the last minute so my dad my mom
uh she said she got a message from Jesus
um through I think it was the placement
of a blanket on her bed she said if the
blanket is you know in a certain way
then I'll do it and if it's not I won't
all right and um uh my dad he he asked
it's a big decision to put to the
blanket really is my Dad decided Well I
just did you know to the drama and I
said hey Paul could we just do something
softer like mushrooms which I was just
you know Dad this is a holy indigenous
right you can't just say oh could you
cut the chameleon one with some Diet
Sprite yeah I'd love to add to this tank
to fight blood of Christ but if you got
two rocks and a line back there
you know I somehow listened to the bed
and I must have just tuned out that they
didn't do it I don't know how I missed
it yeah and I was I was I was so scared
for them because I you know but they
yeah and I know people who have had just
wonderful experiences and it does help I
I mean there's Medical
literature I'll be that guy yeah
evidence that mushrooms and psychedelics
do help with death uh fear fear and a
ketamine you know that my husband just
tried ketamine um and he yeah you'd have
to ask him but I don't I don't know if
it was something he wants to do again
um but it was pricey which that feels
good when you
throw some cash at something it's like
ah now I I mean uh I really dig
something but um as someone who's done
ketamine I would imagine he would like
to do it again yeah yeah well he's
he's just like getting high and then you
come back to reality and go huh
all right interesting I've heard it
framed other ways my experience was
atypical I think but a lot of people the
um the Euphoria of it emboldens them to
do Shadow work is is they say the same
thing about Ayahuasca is there's like a
there's a Oneness of feeling of unity
that you then go back from while you're
still on the drug and go like okay I can
look at this this or this whether it be
a fear of death imagine just feeling so
connected to everything that your own
death becomes as inconsequential as like
whether or not I picked this up and put
it back down and then you're not afraid
so you're like okay let's talk about us
think about it it's it's like it's kind
of like that cool yeah well yeah he said
he was inside the color brown that
sounds about right and then then it was
over and uh I believe it was four
hundred dollars that's a lot of money
and then um he had to go back through
the Metro System of Los Angeles which is
a whole other dimension in itself so
yeah I I don't I don't know we'll we'll
see we'll see how many times have you
done it I just did it once once okay
yeah yeah
would you recommend it then or
I would you know who it really helped
too with Gary gallman who came up oh
nice in my mind earlier yes he had some
uh good experiences from that because it
helped him transcend a very crippling
depression yes of course yes yes it
would do that it would take you out but
then it unfortunately puts you uh back
you know it's not a cure but it is a
break take yeah it gives you a break in
the break you can kind of go like where
am I in the Maze these aren't Gary's
words I'm just saying that's kind of the
idea yeah I would you know I do
recommend it to people but not to
everybody it would certainly depend on
yeah a professional or whatever yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna put that responsibility
you're going to want to talk to a
professional yeah and a professional
it's also so hearty like I have a
psychiatrist he takes my insurance so
that's why I love him
um
my texts which I believe is not a good
care but um it's only emojis it's fine
it's fine it's the guy walking in the
whole Emoji he says he texts I'll text
him he'll text me back and go let's
count this as an appointment be like you
do you you do you Dr Shaw that's account
this is an appointment you should write
back let's count this as a live concert
you owe me 75 you owe Ticketmaster 75
and me 75 well I I I've heard you
reference being an atheist before
um I'm curious I'm just worried I'm
checking the time no check the time
we're wrapping up we're out of here okay
okay this is the last okay
we can even skip it okay okay no no no
okay no no that wasn't passive
aggressive I'm like this is your episode
we've done so much yes uh the time we've
been going 90 minutes Jesus Christ yeah
that's where we're at that's plenty
nobody needs more than you'd you'd be
surprised oh wow a lot of people out
there this is very Maria Bamford a lot
of people out there with driving jobs a
lot of people out there with data entry
jobs things that they don't need their
full mental so they can get involved and
they love a long form so they're they're
with you they'll enjoy it okay don't you
dare tweet them a word that that
indicates that they made it to this
point in this episode banana bread
um I scooped a for breakfast I had a
scoop of peanut butter and a Diet Coke
and that's one of the many recipes that
you'll find in my new book
um uh sure I'll join your cult
sure I'll join your cult yeah I was I
had to promote something because I I
know I loved it it just sounded so much
like you said Cheryl join your call sure
oh no no have you ever been in a well
you were in Christianity I was in
Christianity which I consider more of a
kink
it's so kinky oh yeah I think about it
it's I'm not trying to be disrespectful
I'm just saying when I look back on my
own relationship to God at that time
there was a very like a quest to play
Equus there's a real like God knows I'm
a piece of [__] he's after me yeah you
know what I mean it just kind of makes
your nips tingle a little bit you just
are like oh what's he gonna do and and
it uh when you mix sexuality into that
and the evil of it and you want it so
bad it's almost like you know when you
like go off chocolate from um to eat
chocolate and make it better it's almost
like that idea got smeared into a whole
part of our biology to actually kind of
like
overtly or maybe unintentionally make it
hotter yeah I had a Christian
Evangelical Christian roommate in
college who when her boyfriend and her
got too hot and heavy with the making
out yeah they would get down on their
knees and pray together I'm sure for the
feelings to go away and I said that is
the [__] hottest thing I've ever
heard in my life it is I I've said this
a million but I'm going to say it to you
there our pastor was fired or like
disbarred or whatever it is the elders
booted him because he had sex with
someone he was counseling and I was like
I I know of course yes of course it's
like a cliche
um I understand there's a power Dynamic
I I don't know the details um I just
know there's a lot of different ways to
look at this as I'm realizing before I
say my riff I'm just saying they fell in
love they started having sex and I'm
like you can't get hotter yeah you can't
get hotter than we're going to hell for
this like that's it's the ultimate yeah
like uh what's the word not cosplay but
it's like oh my God I I want it's like
Pride and Prejudice like I know our
family is off
like biblical biblically yeah like old
school God is like gonna [__] get me
if he catches us so we better do it
behind these [__] bushes my father so
that we could give the more children of
Israel what's that one that's lat is
that no uh uh lot's daughters Lots
daughters oh that they're banging on his
door and they give him his other
daughters to us to rape I'm sorry
there's no other way to say it well yeah
I The Story Goes they leave Kasam gonora
uh his wife looks back she turns into a
pillar of salt all he has is his two
daughters they get their dad drunk
sorry sorry then they rape their father
um so that they can continue the tribe
events oh yeah they want to get pregnant
yeah
don't think that how I don't think
that's how that went down but uh there's
another story I was confusing it with
another horrible story which was they
wanted to rape somebody and they sent
out someone else they were like well you
can't have them but here's the other it
like I don't even know who that is yeah
there's a lot of Goof Troop in that
there's a lot of Goof Troop in there all
that aside formalized religion aside you
know when we were talking about ketamine
an experience of Oneness and even
science would talk about the quantum
field or or like the the the singularity
the lowest point of everything being
kind of in this map or what I'm what I'm
really saying is like the big bang is
the idea that everything was one thing
and it expanded yes
um I'm wondering if you have any sort of
feeling about reality other than just
like
a rock and mammals and living and dying
is there a bigger picture for Maria
Bamford
I just wish I know that should be your
only answer and I'll always remember
that you just went
no and would never forget it okay
because it's great no but now I do want
to hear all your thoughts if you if you
want I don't know I don't know I I yeah
I mean I think I am limited uh I wish I
had more thoughts uh that'd be great
um but I seem to um I circulate in a
certain uh uh pattern
um because it's fun and uh what's the
pattern the pattern is
um well this one seems to still get me I
get triggered or whatever by I go oh uh
you can't go out because you're old and
filthy and unattractive okay so that's
an exciting thought and then I go oh but
you're also uh nobody wants to talk to
you because you're not uh of any worth
and then uh then I trigger on for that
and I go oh but what about the thing
where you're uh not good enough to be
outside then I go back to oh I better
stay inside and that's that's a little
circle I run it every day and I usually
can pop myself out of it with a Nitro
cold brew uh which what I did prior to
this uh talk and I hope I hope uh yeah I
was I was really here you were purposely
here and you know I know what you're
describing isn't logic based it's not
it's not evidence-based it's it's no
it's a bananas it's absolute trash
because that's why I was gonna say me
saying like you're worthy it's wonderful
to talk to you you're a treasure it's
not it's not the solution but I am still
gonna say it well thank you it's
wonderful talking and it's wonderful
talking to you too and it's wonderful to
come into your home
be seeing people's
home I thought you I almost went into
the house across the street and I got
real scared because it was very art like
it's an articulated fancy home and I'm
like oh [__] they do this yeah uh like I
I'm Really Gonna Be monstrous yeah and
then because I make things dirty as soon
as I enter them and now I'm like well
this seems much more colorful playful
like a lived-in look yeah I love it hang
out thank you I I we have lived in place
there's lots of I've got a pack of books
that you can put a drink on yeah
yep yeah
um I'm not adverse to a cobweb in the
corner oh
biters hanging happily hanging happily
it looks like they're the most unhappy
you can be it's a suicide joke
you see a spider and you're like oh no
he's quite he's hanging quite happily oh
he's hanging yes no he's he's got stuff
to do well I am delighted thank you so
much for having me and allowing me to
wrap it up
I can't possibly talk anymore all right
Delight thank you thank you thank you
thank you 100 a joke uh would you say
keep it crispy you've said it before we
needed the live show it's just how we
say goodbye keep it crispy
thank you Maria your new book Cheryl
join your cult is available September
September goodbye nice
so wonderful thank you
[Music]